you are morally obligated to do
remarkable things why life is short and
can be brutal can terrify you into
hiding and avoiding you can flip that on
its head and understand that since
you're all in anyways you might as well
take the risks that are adventurous
there isn't anything more adventurous
than the truth you aren't necessarily
the best judge of what you need it's
easy to be diluted in what you want
that's the sort of delusions that people
chase if they chase power so why is that
a moral obligation if you hide and you
don't let what's inside of you out and
you don't bring into the world what you
could bring and you become cynical and
bitter you will start doing very dark
things being jealous of people who are
competent and doing well and work to
destroy them that's the pathway to hell